people haven't been very friendly the
guy says that he's surprised considering
it felt like a nice and somewhat
affluent neighborhood and given the
price he was expecting friendly
neighbors I asked if they have done any
research about the area they said they
moved from California so no
oh she just stealed her face
from Ohio I don't know
and that's where she knew she sounds
like a red pill dude oh my God
the gender roles were reversed yeah it'd
be like oh my gosh this guy's trapping
this one yes yes 100 she's like she's a
sociopath yeah he needs to move out
immediately he thinks I have no right to
say anything about his love life even
though it's my best friend and I'm doing
so much for him my best friend she owns
this person yeah she owns both of them
yeah and she didn't she's like little
dollies yeah
what the [ __ ] she's not an [ __ ]
[ __ ] would be a compliment at this
point
[Music]
hi welcome back to another episode of
big mood how you doing I missed you not
really
look who's here first of all we have a
special guest yeah tell us who you are
who's your special guest
no my name's Jay
um and yeah I do like some some comedy
stuff on the side I have a full-time job
a mom of two and uh yeah I'm really
happy to be here I'm super excited I
love this show I'm glad you guys asked
me to be here I appreciate it absolutely
we're gonna go around the room so you're
gonna even one special thing about
yourself
um first of all I'd like to point out
that we have Nikki limo back on the show
everybody missed me I'm sure
I know you do
you have fans too
and of course me I'm here it's Jess from
Austin I'm here you got me here
she took a break from her corporate job
yeah yeah
and uh it's me Gina um so we're today's
uh I'm hosting this one because we're
doing am I the [ __ ] which is like my
most favorite thing in the world uh and
I'm gonna just pull a bunch of am I the
[ __ ] threads on Reddit and we're I'm
gonna read it out to you guys it's my
first time seeing it too so I don't know
what the hell these are we're gonna
react to it and tell them if they're an
[ __ ] why or why not just just Grill
and just roast them if you want to I'm
kidding I thought this was going to be
where I get to tell a story of why I'm
an [ __ ] oh and you can't do much
better you can't and we'll tell you if
you're the [ __ ] I do like judging
others better than myself exactly this
is yeah this is we get to take a break
from being bad people and we get to
judge other people yes okay I'm very
excited that's why I love doing this so
much okay so
the first one is uh am I the [ __ ] for
feeding my dog table scraps from a
dinner my boyfriend made for us
all right the story is I 24 year old
female has been dating Jay 28 year old
male for four months he is handsome
smart funny well educated has an awesome
job and is a sweetheart someday tell him
to call me Sunday he had a whole day
planned for us we were going to walk a
nature trail then go back to his place
for dinner he was making I was so
excited because it was going to be the
first time I'd be at his house since we
were hiking he said I could bring my dog
Shelby with us he made us a roast and
some vegetables for dinner I finished my
plate before jaded and took it to the
kitchen there was still about half the
roast left and it was close to Shelby's
dinner time so I took half of the half
of the roast and some still raw
vegetables from the fridge to put on the
plate for Shelby I was carrying the
plate to the back door with Shelby to
feed her outside and Jay asked me what I
was doing I told him feeding Shelby Jay
said something like well that's not dog
food Jay knows I mainly feed Shelby a
raw diet I opened the door to put the
plate down for Shelby and Jay got up
took the plate from her went to the
kitchen came back with it wrapped in
tinfoil and told me to leave his excuse
was that he made dinner for me and him
not me him and my dog and that I should
have asked before I helped myself since
he would have used his leftovers I did
leave but not before telling him that he
made the meal for us so I could do with
some of it as I pleased and he knew damn
well I feed Shelby uh I tried talking to
my friend about it later that night but
she said Jay was right to be upset but
this friend has never really approved of
how I treat my own dog so I feel like
she was probably a bit biased and a
wrong person to ask am I the [ __ ] for
feeding my dog like I normally would
clarification she does not get
restaurant Food daily I eat out maybe
four times a month if what I eat is dog
safe at the restaurant makes food or the
restaurant makes foods for dogs on
request then I bring some home for her
Shelby's daily meals are a bit of brown
rice raw vegetables and ground chicken
hearts and beef livers the heart livers
are boiled just enough to kill bacteria
and that is all the approval or those
with the privilege so that the dog
people don't come for her yeah that's
all I asked James okay that's fair I
asked you how he prepared the rose so I
could uh I could know if it was safe to
give her there's also that's also why I
got her fresh unused vegetable from the
fridge am I the [ __ ] Jay's the
[ __ ] Jay's [ __ ] that is a
boyfriend well first of all she's going
a little like too far into I mean I
gotta
okay do you mind if I just go over there
so so I have two dogs and
um they're called puggle cheese because
they're pug mix it's I will show you
a couple of Spencers are like 13 years
old now but yeah anyway so spinsters
like I when we make like dinner like
let's say we have steak or something
right and you never eat your whole
there's always like a little bit of you
know whatever's left and sometimes we'll
mix it in with their food and give it to
them and it's like they love that it's
like a treat for them you know the fact
that like this guy asked her to leave
makes him a total [ __ ] I'm like are
you kidding me what are you what are we
talking about it's not like she
pretended to like it didn't eat any of
her food and I was like here give it to
the dog at the table because at first I
thought is she feeding the door yeah
yeah that's a little bit of a dick move
and it's not smart and it's kind of just
whatever there's a whole other weird
problems yeah feed a dog at the table
too it's also like after you get up yeah
like the fact that she went through all
this trouble to like I don't see the
problem with it I'm like and if he's
being that significant about [ __ ] the
dog being fed a meal like move on yeah
are you kidding to be the Step Daddy of
your dog no no he's gonna kick the dog
when you're not home yeah exactly yeah
he's not a dog person obviously Jay is
not a dog person Devil's Advocate yep
what if this is a very expensive piece
of prime meat okay but what's the
difference between it being in her
intestines and yeah in her dog it would
have become scraped into the tree I
guess no I guess if it's like a really
expensive prime meat and it took like 16
hours to cook or some [ __ ] like that and
he like put all this effort into it he's
like
I get you putting maybe the scrap of
like a regular Choice Cut whatever and
the dog's plate but I spent a lot of
time and money on this meat like this
cut of meat so like this wasn't intended
for the dog because this like I went
above and beyond for this meal so like
it kind of feels like you're giving my
energy and my effort and my money into
your dog's bowl which is like a
throwaway Devil's Advocate I agree I get
that yeah I get that I also would say to
that though that if but I see her
believe was a lot so that's what I was
gonna say is like one uh have an adult
conversation yeah like use your words
yeah use your words otherwise there's no
communication relationships [ __ ] anyway
um a two like if you're gonna spend all
that money like what is he gonna do eat
her leftovers or like yeah maybe what if
she took it home with her and then fed
her dog at home yeah exactly yeah if he
didn't know then obviously he's not
gonna kill him I guess like if he found
that rude instead of kicking her out he
could have explained why he was a little
by it yeah totally yeah I agree with
that um I agree with just like if it was
super expensive like if I got you a
[ __ ] prime rib or I made you a beef
wellington and you [ __ ] give it to
the dog a little bit weird I if I
weren't her I would have asked for a
second is it okay if I give some to my
dog this is so good I want her you know
like that
um but I feel like it would be a little
bit weird if she's made her way to the
kitchen and just made a huge plate and
just gave it to the dog without asking I
will say taking fresh raw vegetables
from his fridge that is for her first
time over at his house that's a little
too much making yourself at home but
she's a little bit of a Nutty dog owner
because there's a lot of description
into how this stuff this dog's eating
better than I do yeah my dog is and I
like kibble so so yeah like what are we
doing and I have my dogs are on great
dog food and I'm like I'm not doing for
what what are we talking about
chicken hearts and [ __ ]
or like if this guy was someone who you
know doesn't make a lot of money so
that's another thing I was thinking and
he wanted to eat the leftovers still but
again these are all communication yeah
with your best friend here yeah because
some of the best things in our
relationship or when we had like an
argument over something where we
completely saw things different ways but
then we communicated about them yeah and
that makes your relationship stronger if
you can't communicate through conflict
then yeah we're even doing it yeah that
whole relationship is a waste of time so
Reddit all together uh decided she is
the [ __ ]
so the top comment is
the top comment is yes you're the
[ __ ] you're now ex-boyfriend made a
special meal for you you took a large
hunk of that special meal and gave it to
your dog not only that but you did so
knowing it would upset your boyfriend
you should get it did she knows
I'm forgiving yeah can we rate the
commenters
said uh you should have fed you should
not have fed Shelby with people food you
should have brought food that you
already knew food forward because you
knew you're gonna be there and you
should particularly not have fed your
dog with special dinner your boyfriend
prepared for you it is wholly relevant
that Jay quote Jay knows you mainly feed
Shelby raw diet nobody cares uh the next
top comment well you guys read all of
this in comments apparently they care
yeah uh the next comment is also you're
the [ __ ] a quarter of a rose is not
uh table scraps how's the fact that you
mainly feed your dog a raw diet at all
relevant also holy entitlement Batman at
you made the dinner for me so I can do
with it as I please by that logic I
would have been perfectly it would have
been perfectly acceptable to flush it
down cool so we're not dating any of you
my takeaway is our society is [ __ ] but
this is what people are saying yeah
another one says [ __ ] disappointed
like you take yourself way too seriously
like how is your day today are you like
that serious bro like oh I spent five
dollars on this a quarter of a quarter
of a freaking steak Yeah well also this
is the first time that she's over right
yeah don't spend that kind of [ __ ]
money then if it was that you know what
I mean or like make it go get a New York
strip and call it a day it could have
been lovely compared this you know I
like you make it more like momentum that
it's like so special that you like
definitely don't feed the dog so special
the dog's not coming with you because
we're gonna have a candle lit dinner and
it's gonna be this whole sexy night see
we could date yeah things don't work out
with our husbands another one says
you're the [ __ ] half the rose let me
introduce you to this New Concept called
leftovers it's not table scraps when you
set table scraps we thought like little
bits and pieces of cups of fat but you
gave them half a [ __ ] roast that is a
lot of fun that is it is a lot of food
right I don't own dogs it seems like
maybe he took it as like I prepared this
whole roast and you gave like such a
large piece of the dog you're trying to
get rid of it or something yeah like I
would have just eaten that yeah yeah I
could see it being offensive a better
thing for her to do in in his defense
would have been just take the dog hide
it in your underwear give it to the dog
don't be [ __ ] rude yeah but she's
clearly such a dog Mom that she wouldn't
that's like
yeah she wasn't even thinking like oh he
won't he won't agree with me and that's
a big part of her personality though so
like if he was to stick with her and by
the way they were like boyfriend but
like it's been four months like chilling
calm down calm down yeah that's the
first time you're going over to his
house that's crazy oh that to me is
really weird I'm changing my answer
they're both [ __ ]
they're just they both are [ __ ] in
their own way almost to a point where
they deserve each other to be honest
like you're both meant to be single for
me it'd be like I think it was the
amount like if it was yeah it was a lot
but it's like half a [ __ ] roast and
the vegetables in the fridge then kind
of put me over there I think it depends
on how you were raised a little bit too
like is your dog like a dog and a little
bit separate from the family or is your
dog like a part of your family people
have different you know like respect for
their dogs so she clearly has a lot of
respect for her dogs
it's like a human and if I was like
you're way too obsessed with your dog
I'm like that's not a good fit and I
would go like a normal person yeah
after she just got talking about how
communication
ghosting is also there are times when
yeah I've never ghosted anyone and I
promise all right the next one is am I
the [ __ ] for making my husband fly
coach while I flew first class nope
this is fantastic absolutely not okay
you are a queen yes Queen I don't know
why I'm not sure oh if it's the same
flight that's all right we're gonna read
this so excited my husband 33 male my
husband's company recently chose him to
attend a conference in Miami they chose
just him and his few of his co-workers
that have a ton of candidates it was
quite the honor the company told him
that they were allowed to bring their
spouses but that but that they wouldn't
be springing for plane tickets for us so
if they wanted to bring us they'd have
to buy tickets out of their own Pockets
my husband asked me if I wanted to go
and I am
emphatically told him that I did I'd
never been to Florida in my life and I
thought I'd it'd be a fun trip he told
me great but when we went to the website
to buy tickets he asked if it's okay
with flying coach even though he'd be
flying first class on the way there and
coach on the way home I asked him why he
couldn't just why we couldn't just fly
together and he replied first class is
just so expensive I feel bad but we just
can't afford it especially if we want to
go out and have fun in Miami the flight
is only a few hours this really really
bothered me I understood that a first
class ticket for me would strain our
budget a bit but what kind of man lives
It Up In First Class while his wife sits
and Coach it was free for him
I asked him just that and he responded
come on I'm taking you along on a work
trip I earned my first class seat by
working hard it's my reward but I insist
that if we truly couldn't afford first
class seat for me he could have it would
have just hurt a little bit but we could
have uh I insist that if he was a
gentleman uh he should give up his seat
for me we argued but he ultimately
agreed to give me his seat we had a good
time in Miami but he's been a little mad
at me since saying that he earned his
first class seat that it was free and
cost us nothing unlike my plane ticket
and that I should have just let him
enjoy what he'd earned this [ __ ] needs
a hobby yeah
tell me she saves kids or she works for
a charity tell me she does something she
better be doing something
years later right what the [ __ ] we're
not going to [ __ ] Dubai in a real
first class seat right this is just some
[ __ ] it's a chair that's foreign
leave now and I'll meet you there uh
unbelievable he said that I should have
just let him enjoy what he'd earned
instead of quote guilting him out of it
yes enjoy his one glass of champagne and
four inches yeah he gets no other
Pleasures who cares she sounds like she
robs him of all she's married to a total
[ __ ] lunatic so give him at least 10
minutes about two hours people are so
lame um I think he's being a baby and
this whole problem is what this is I
think he's being a baby and that he
should have put his wife's Comfort above
his own especially since he made the
choice to be cheap we're very close to
his parents
we're very close to his parents so we've
taken this argument to them for
mediation but they are split oh no his
parents they're split his father agrees
with me that he wasn't being a gentleman
while his mother thinks that he earned
his first class seat and that I should
have let him down he's trying to get
brownies so am I mommy yeah oh God
they're all [ __ ] idiots
is when you have billions of dollars
dollars and you're still like no you fly
coach I play last class like being like
it's gonna really strain our budget and
we can't have a good time in Miami if we
buy a first class yeah she did say it
would hurt yeah
okay what do you value more then okay
then we can't go out to dinner and then
she'd be like am I the [ __ ] for
wanting a nice dinner after I got a
first class ticket yeah
you can't have it always lady
um I hate these people yeah
and I think that they're both [ __ ]
she's an [ __ ] and I don't think I
need to explain why I feel like Anyone
who reads this is going to go or is this
woman out of her [ __ ] mind like come
on dude right also we don't know their
the in the intimacies of their finances
and how things are but she did say as
right as she wants to be about this she
did admit that it would hurt a little
yeah probably would hurt more than she
said because she's also trying to plead
her case of why she's right right so
let's assume yes their trip would have
suffered in some way they wouldn't have
been able to do something fun maybe they
would have had to be like really tight
for the next month or two because they
got that seat first class tickets are
thousands of dollars in compared to it's
not worth it coach tickets especially
for a few hours yeah and it's like and
and to do that it's like yeah he did
work hard for it that was his reward and
he didn't he could have said I'm just
gonna go on this thing he wanted to
bring his wife if they could have made
it go right to be in first class
together I'm sure he sounds like the
kind of guy that would have made that
happen he's taking her to begin with you
know but he's an [ __ ] for putting up
with this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
I would literally ever be in this
situation oh my God
I'm very angry there's a very yeah
we married this person to begin with so
this isn't even a Rolodex of options in
our mind that can happen I honestly
don't think that of domestic first class
flight is worth even batting an eye at
it's machine [ __ ] boring it's like
lame as [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about a
domestic person but I'd be so happy if
Steve got the first class ticket because
he's always bitching about it yeah is he
tall yeah oh my God yeah he's like I
can't even it's so uncomfortable no yeah
he has to fly first class absolutely
yeah like he earned this dude yeah let
him enjoy this yeah
it's [ __ ] lame it's whack what
they're fighting over is lame yeah a
first class seat on a domestic flight on
[ __ ] American Airlines is [ __ ] it
sucks it's black there's nothing to
fight over this is like fighting over
[ __ ] dirt yeah it's so they're
inventing problems now I feel like like
there's real legitimate problems people
couples have this is not that okay move
on with your [ __ ] although the number
one reason people get divorced is
because of finances so you're just like
kind of yeah yeah just sticking a knife
in there and it's actually looking for
something is what she's doing it's like
Let Your Man enjoy something man she
seems like the type of person it's like
happy wife happy happy life yeah you
know yes dear is the way to go he's
miserable isn't that normal exactly he
has to sacrifice every single [ __ ]
thing every single [ __ ] time or he's
not a gentleman yeah you're gonna drain
him and drain him he's gonna drain him
yeah
don't talk to me until I've had my
coffee yeah exactly uh the top comment
is your well I mean a majority of it uh
of all the comments uh determined that
you're the [ __ ] thank God his company
the first class ticket for him what kind
of wife insists her husband give up the
ticket the com his company paid for on
his PF so she could quote live it up a
little why did you discover the cost uh
difference at first of first class
yourself sorry did she get to read this
oh yeah yeah she gets to see all this
um and then she's the one that posted it
yeah
uh second comment says you're the
[ __ ] what kind of wife puts her
Comfort above that of her husband's
you're a hypocrite and you cheated him
out of something he earned and deserved
just for your personal enjoyment I can't
believe he gave it to her too yeah yeah
uh he didn't have to bring you to
Florida quote off our hand they'll take
an arm that's you I actually want to see
what her responses were she deleted her
account oh [ __ ]
that's what they usually do when like
it's overwhelming yeah because they
really think that everyone's gonna be
like oh yeah girl you go yeah like it
doesn't go that way girl power this is
what feeds the mgtow guys yeah
I would do this to you hope you're happy
yeah that's what you get for sleeping
with a woman yeah succubus woman
yeah uh you're the [ __ ] not so much
for the seat situation more so your
whole outlook on this Venture exactly
this was his moment his trip he wanted
to share that with you he didn't have to
but it seems that it seems like that in
that in itself wasn't good enough for
you so yes you are the [ __ ] oh my God
at least there's some hope for mankind
thank God that's [ __ ] awful that
reminds me of when I went to Hawaii and
I ran into you guys and my ex-boyfriend
was like
um even though we were flying home to
different cities yeah this was like
years ago uh my ex-boyfriend and I were
in Hawaii for a wedding and then they
happened to be in Hawaii they flew in
did you know they were there uh yes but
they flew in the day that we were
supposed to leave he and I were flying
to two different cities because we were
long distance I paid for my own flight
okay and then I'm like hey my friends
are here I'm gonna stay a few more days
and spend the weekend with them he's
like no like why he goes well if I have
to go home you have to go home too what
yeah I'm like what do you mean he goes
well that's not fair like I have to go
home and work and you you get to like
yeah life isn't fair bro yeah you're not
gonna he's not even gonna be with you
anyway exactly we're not flying home
together I paid for this ticket what the
[ __ ] yeah and then it came down to like
a year just misery loves company kind of
[ __ ] yes a year later he was like if I
can't be happy you're not yeah we should
be equally unhappy yeah yeah years later
a year later he was like well it's not
fair that you get to still do this whole
entertainment because he was an
Entertainer but he had to take over his
family business and be miserable nine to
five that's why so you needed to also do
that yeah it's just jealous exactly this
sounds like I would have had a break
yeah
Jesus Christ does your probiotic contain
clinically studied strains well need one
that does rituals symbiotic plus
contains two of the world's most studied
strains with over 350 publications of
human clinical trials I really like
ritual symbiotic plus because I like
that it has a Prebiotic a probiotic and
a postbiotic so I have all of them in
one and my gut health is in order with
just one pill and it doesn't upset my
stomach at all hopefully you will like
it as much as I like it the delayed
release capsules designed to help reach
the colon not just the stomach which is
an ideal place for the probiotics to
survive and grow and there is no
Refrigeration needed it's designed with
moisture controlled bottle technology to
help protect the probiotic strains
symbiotic plus and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides there's
no more shame in your gut game that's
why ritual is offering our listeners 10
off during the first three months visit
ritual.com big mood to start ritual or
add synbiotic plus to subscription today
that's ritual.com big mood next one is
am I the [ __ ] for refusing to babysit
my niece and leaving her with a stranger
instead
I stopped there yes
there's any explanation I need no I need
more information on the stranger because
sometimes people just put headlines if
somebody gets attention maybe better the
kid is yes I I feel like there's more to
this story so let's just take it should
be I female 24 years old I am an aunt to
my one-year-old Baltimore 24. pretty
young they're all a bunch of [ __ ]
dumb asses
um I'm an answer my one-year-old niece
Ava my sister one year old niece she's
an [ __ ]
my sister and brother-in-law-in-law live
close to me so I babysit for them
sometimes they don't pay me but I'm
happy to do it anyways are you okay on
Friday was their anniversary and they
asked me three weeks in advance if I
could babysit I provisionally agreed
because I have nothing else planned my
plans changed however when some of my
old College friends told me they were
stopping by my town on Friday I haven't
seen them in nearly three years and
really wanted to see them like three
years it's been an eternity yeah three
[ __ ] years sorry go ahead
um I gave my five days notice that I
could no longer babysit on Friday and
that she should make other arrangements
she didn't respond to a text but she
read it so I assumed it was okay on
Friday however sister stopped by my
house with Ava I was confused and asked
her why she was here she told me she was
leaving Ava with me as originally
planned I said again I was busy she
replied that family is more important
than my quote silly College friends whoa
okay and I should step up to my
responsibility as an aunt before I could
protest she bolted back to her car where
brother-in-law was and they dreamed
about the [ __ ] for sure too 100 so
weird also they drove off leaving Ava
with me I tried to call her after she
left but she had her phone off and none
of my calls went through
okay that's a terrible responsibility as
a parent yeah I get the whole you're an
aunt because I do this with my sister
sometimes too but my kids are my
responses yes
I didn't know what to do I couldn't
leave Eva alone but I also didn't want
to cancel my plans there's no other
family members who live near me however
I do have a friend Jade who lives near
she is good with kids and does
babysitting as a side hustle I called
her and explained the situation even
offering to pay her to look after Ava
but she was understanding and said she'd
do it for free I thanked her profusely
and dropped Ava off I texted my sister
to say I left Ava with Jade and to
collect her from her house it's relevant
to the story that neither sister nor Ava
know Jade personally I mean yeah okay
she's not gonna be like excuse me sir
yes yeah my sister didn't respond
immediately but after about two hours
she started spamming my phone I turned
my phone off as I was already out by
that point anyways how's it feel
this is a huge family crisis they picked
up Ava later that evening and she was
perfectly happy however my sister and
brother-in-law are furious at me for
quote dumping Ava with a stranger what
are they dumpster yeah exactly even
though they know their phone off even
though one year old I'm sorry even
though they know Jade is a trusted
friend of mine they accuse me of
endangering my own niece many other
family members have sided with them and
I've been getting angry texts all
weekend I really don't know what to
think I felt like I acted as best as I
could given the circumstance it's a
woman first of all and it's a woman who
moonlights and babysitting too so what's
she's [ __ ] proflied she's a friend
and you dumped your kid with me yeah
ultimately giving me the decision I'm
now a responsible party I get to decide
what happens with your kids and it
showed that she read the text and she
that means yeah and she ignored that and
didn't confront the situation yeah and
brought her a kid anyway the kid is one
I would say I'm not talking about like a
seven-year-old or like who's a little
bit more self-sufficient that's an
infant she [ __ ] dropped that baby off
she slammed the door I don't necessarily
agree with the fact that I mean I I love
the fact that she knew this girl and the
girl was a babysitter
as a parent if my sister did that I
would be upset but I would be more upset
because I have a similar transgression
of dumping my [ __ ] kid off you see
what I'm saying like they're so jacked
up about that yeah because they just do
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] with their baby
they're it's not it's not their kid it's
their baby okay
and literally like imagine like this is
you know Tiff's son in four months is
eight months old right yeah he's like so
like imagine he's still a baby and being
like here and then turn your phone off
yeah exactly you turned your phone off
you're put your to not have any
information on your baby and to just be
like I don't know it's my sister she'll
take whatever reason it's so zero
responsibility and shitty as a parent
that I'm like you're you're the bigger
[ __ ] yes 100 yeah like I can't yeah
that's so horrifying I agree there's no
situation to me where if you are not in
full control that you can blame anyone
else no like it's always unless you
[ __ ] got hit by a car yeah like
there's no reason you can blame anyone
else for anything they did yeah
um consensus says you are not the
[ __ ] yes your sister asked you three
weeks in advance but five days is plenty
warning that you wanted to change plans
yeah the fact she didn't call you back
or try to negotiate with you just drop
your knee and just drop the niece off
and ran isn't funny or cute she's a
parent and her kid is her and her
husband's responsibility not yours
welcome to Parenthood she's she seems to
be confused on this point you don't owe
her free babysitting at all her antics
of drop and dash and then triangulating
other family as flying monkeys to guilt
trip you okay we'll get out of here with
the narcissistician come on uh it's
childish selfish and disrespectful uh
disrespectful so for the foreseeable
future no matter what when she asks you
to sit tell her no make her reach out to
other mommy friends get into babysitter
Coop or gasp yeah she doesn't pay her
either yeah I would never I would be
like I'm not babysitting anymore no no
uh the second one says spend time with
my niece to be like a good aunt but I'm
not yeah yeah second one says not the
[ __ ] please text back to her and say
I did you a favor and not calling the
police when you dropped off your child
knowing I was about to leave the house
next time I'll just call the police so
your child won't be traumatized by being
babysat by one of my friends also I feel
like the family probably agrees with the
the mom the sister that's the mom
because they're hearing only her side
yeah exactly I guarantee you she's
calling everyone in the family like can
you imagine what she did and you're like
you're hearing one weird [ __ ] version
of the story and they don't have all the
information you know what I mean like
she probably didn't tell them like oh
yeah she totally texted me saying she
wasn't available but yeah anyways
exactly yeah
um consensus is yeah no not the [ __ ]
yeah your sister is yep agreed all right
next one is am I the [ __ ] for
threatening to kick out my co-worker
roommate for kissing my best friend okay
give it to me one more time am I the
[ __ ] for threatening to kick out my
co-worker roommate for kissing my best
friend she lives with her this person
lives with her roommate need more
information as a best friend Mary yeah
what's the scene all right you're single
no you like Get over yourself I'm sorry
around February I let my co-worker Jaden
and his daughter Leah six years old move
in we were co-workers and friends for
three years and he's always been so
funny smart and cute
okay oh she had a crush I was just gonna
say she's jealous yeah we became really
close friends unfortunately work decided
they can't afford to keep everyone and
have been making cuts and Jaden was
basically forced to quit I know he was
really worried about his rent and
everything and my roommate was leaving
so I offered him to stay with me and we
worked out an agreement we decided that
while he's still looking for a job he'd
deal with all the chores and errands and
housework it's honestly been amazing and
having him or it's been amazing having
him live with me he's such a great cook
and Leah has actually been really well
behaved and sweet he's a pretend
boyfriend
he's helped me out a lot and I really
enjoy being able to spend all his time
with him he has found some part-time
work but nothing that pays enough for
him to live alone so we've mostly kept
our agreement just with me doing more
and him helping pay a little my friends
have come over quite a few times and
obviously met him last weekend I had a
bunch of my friends stay over I thought
it was great but the next day Leah told
me she saw Jaden kiss my best friend I
was really upset and Jade and I ended up
arguing about it I told him how betrayed
I felt she's playing she's a delusional
yeah
she's she's oh she's playing house he
tried to say it was fine that uh
apparently that kiss quote wasn't
intentional and he didn't mean anything
because he owes her no accident yeah
exactly two consenting adults kissed
he's freaking out now because he's about
to get kicked out yeah yeah he's just
trying to he's a roof over his hat yeah
don't make relief um but it's still
wrong I'm doing so much only for him to
do this to me what she has delusional
she wants way more than she's like yikes
she has no idea that you're in love with
him yeah he's living with single white
people I think he might know yeah
he's in a relationship he doesn't even
know he's in yeah Jesus Christ he
cheated and he doesn't yeah yeah yeah
um he's so [ __ ] up is she 24 too yes
she's 23. okay she's gonna say she's 23.
um let's see I got upset and told him
that he will have to leave if he just
wants to take advantage of my kindness
oh that I don't want to live with
someone who betrays me like that he was
offended and just tried to act like it
was no big deal and I was being crazy
she sounds like a red pill dude oh my
God
the gender roles were reversed yeah it'd
be like oh my gosh this guy's trapping
this yeah yes yes 100 she's like an
intern she's a sociopath yeah he needs
to move out immediately he thinks I have
no right to say anything about his love
life even though he's my best friend and
I'm doing so much for him my best friend
yeah she owns both of them yeah she
didn't they're like little dollies yeah
you need to kiss
all the strings yeah what the [ __ ] she's
not an [ __ ] [ __ ] would be a
compliment at this point our talk didn't
really work but I did talk to my best
friend and she agreed to back off
okay oh God
yikes she's the best friend because
she's willing to be controlled by this
asset uh the last few days have been
horrible and he doesn't think he's done
anything wrong I've tried to talk again
but now he refuses to and has been
really cold and told me that he'll move
out as soon as he can I don't think I've
done anything wrong it's his own fault I
want to I want to work this out but he
shouldn't be going around kissing my
friends
but the fighting has really upset Leah
and obviously Jaden thinks I'm an
[ __ ] even if he's being selfish I
can't wait just skip to the comments
don't even ask us what we think
I just like how do you ever think you're
in the right here like what it was your
CH how were you raised he's leaving
because you know yeah he's in he's gonna
die she's gonna yeah exactly she stays
she's gonna be like misery she bludgeons
and then be like I'll take care of you
yeah
what a loan attack this is a creepy [ __ ]
dude the soft comment is is Jaden aware
that you have feelings for him yeah yes
and that you expected them returned
because of your quote selfless acts of
kindness yeah you're the [ __ ] no
here's a thing
you're not actually being a helpful kind
person because you have an agenda yeah
you're gonna help someone help someone
with no agenda like you're just doing it
because you want to you like how to do a
nice guy not because you have some yeah
some [ __ ]
ulterior motive you know so she
responded to this comments she did
she said I haven't told him but it's not
about that oh my God I haven't told him
so you're right but that is beside the
point yeah
um because of the whole point he doesn't
have to like me back but he can't go
around kissing my friends he and his
daughter would have been homeless if I
didn't help them I mean I mean Leah sees
me as a mother figure now oh he needs to
get out oh she's crazy and I'm afraid
she's listening to us somehow I don't
know how
I feel very violated just like verbally
I feel like anything that comes around I
think that I'm I'm I'm you're on a Hit
List oh my God I think you're a really
good person if you're gonna watch this
oh my God please I do not live in Las
Vegas yeah right yeah Jesus for sure
while we moved out yeah we're totally
gone from that house so don't you look
it up yep nope it's definitely obvious
that she I don't think you're gonna ever
convince this person that they're they
ask you they're so delusional yeah I
don't think an alternate universe she's
not she's gonna have to go through this
probably like 20 times before she's like
oh maybe it's me yeah like she's like
50. no I don't know she might be like
I'll just find the right guys you know
what I mean like that kind of like she's
like in an alternate reality yeah God I
hope she never has kids oh my god oh no
oh my God they're like she's gonna own
those kids yeah she's actually
entrepreneur
yeah my mom does that all the time God
I'm going through her Linda
she lied about her age
um I am going through her comments right
now and it's in all caps I'm not in love
with him how many times do I have to say
oh my God so many people called her out
on that that's so great is there anyone
that doesn't think she's enough right is
yeah is there anyone that was like oh I
got you not at all
um she said not at all she wanted to go
show him and be like see yeah look how
many people agree with me now you can
stay
another another reply from her says it's
not about feelings okay I said it
repeatedly I'm not in love it wasn't
about him liking me I just wanted him to
be okay I I wanted to help him hearing
how worried he was and scared he was for
Leah but I did not want him to have a
good sex life without me yeah I also
just want to like side note he would not
have been homeless he would have figured
out a way to make it go right and find a
place for him and his daughter this is
just like the first option that came up
you're not the only solution and the
be-all end all of this guy like when you
have a kid you figure it out yeah even
if he didn't he would have found a plate
you know yeah come on rewarded with dick
yeah yeah it wasn't yeah you kissed my
BFF now you're just gonna get a bag of
Dick smell to you from all these people
I'm sick of everyone saying that I'm in
love with him I'm not okay it's not
about jealousy I've been saying oh she
said it's all about jealousy
um like I've been saying even if I
wouldn't be okay with the relationship
this would be the same she said I
wouldn't care if he went off and dated
other people just not my best friend it
sounds like she's jealous of her best
friend well yeah yeah yes the best
friend needs to also leave town for her
own and also she wouldn't be okay with
him she's gonna be okay
with it has more control because if the
reason why you're mad is because you've
been so kind to him yes that he didn't
give you that same affection it wouldn't
have matter who the [ __ ] it was it's
just that it's not you it's the actual
problem exactly this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
crazy yeah yeah you know that kind of
like you said she's not kind if she
expected something in return yeah yeah
that's not how that works man insane
[ __ ] dude this is great I love your
transactions right it's very judging
other people if it was going to be
transactional it should add
it
in exchange for sexual favors yeah you
can live here very good kind of
linguists um and and then you also do
the dishes once or twice a week yeah
yeah exactly all right BJ for a for a
steak you know you cook I clean the
holidays can create even more waste than
usual each year Americans throw away 25
more trash from Thanksgiving to New
Year's but what if we told you that
there was a way to get all your holiday
shopping done without the guilty feeling
over the waist that typically comes with
it meet blue land blue land is on a
mission to eliminate single-use plastic
by Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and the planet and this
holiday season blue land is having its
best sale of the year so you can save
and shop sustainably for your friends
family and even yourself the idea is
simple you grab one of the beautiful
forever bottles fill it with warm water
drop in the tablet and get cleaning
refills start at two dollars and you
don't have to buy a new plastic bottle
every time you run out you can even set
up a subscription or buy in bulk so you
never run out of the products you use
the most from cleaning sprays to hand
soap to toilet cleaner and laundry
tablets all blue land products are made
with ingredients that you can feel good
about try their clean Essentials kit
which has everything you need to get
started try their clean Essentials kit
which has everything you need to get
started in signature scents such as Iris
Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus mint
which is my personal favorite Plus for a
limited time blue lands hand soap is
getting a festive upgrade with a
beautiful chocolate box inspired gift
set with cozy scents like Evergreen
Winterberry and peppermint I personally
am such a big fan of the laundry tablets
every time I do my laundry and I just
throw a little tablet in and I receive
my clothes out of of the washer and
they're just so much cleaner like I'm
telling you guys I am so impressed with
blue lens commitment to their cleaning
products they actually clean really well
and I love the fact that there is no
single use plastic waste because of
these little tablets you don't have to
worry about just throwing away plastic
because it's just endless plastic in our
landfills that we do not need so I'm a
really big fan of laundry tablets
personally I also really love the cute
bottles that it comes in and every time
that you fill it up like whenever we run
out of our bottle we just fill it up
with water throw in a tablet and see the
foaming action happen and our house is
nice and clean with the eco-friendly
products that blue land provides
definitely take advantage of their best
sell this year go to blueland.com big
mood you won't want to miss this
blueland.com big mood that's
blueland.com big mood all right next one
is am I the [ __ ] for telling my new
neighbors that they get what they paid
for including being shunned by the whole
neighborhood what oh this is a [ __ ]
starter right here this person's a [ __ ]
story I paint their house purple shocked
by the whole neighborhood this person
started a movement
this is
this wife with no job this is HOA Karen
all right where I live real estate
developers have certain age
no age yet okay yeah right
where I live real she fast walks around
the neighborhood she has advisor advisor
for sure she's a Disney adult she plays
tennis on Saturdays
where I live real estate developers have
started snatching up family homes
bulldozing them and building enormous
enormous two million houses oh America
on the plot of land Welcome To Earth
okay uh the houses also stick out
horribly in form of Aesthetics uh think
like single level brick homes with three
level gigantic white and black box in
the middle yes we know everything I wish
I had this kind of time do you know what
I mean like to notice these horrid out
points so many neighborhoods in Austin
are like these old little ranch homes
and then right next to it is a gigantic
[ __ ] like Farm style yeah it's just
like these Housewives they just don't
have
they don't even have the decency to be
aesthetically pleasing to my stuff yeah
we don't have speed walking in the
neighborhood
we noticed you didn't decorate for
Christmas yeah what's wrong with you are
you Jewish what the [ __ ] can you imagine
living like this this must be hard for
her my home's been in my family for
several Generations we have always been
known for having a large beautiful
garden we invited over kids to play with
gardening we gave away so many veggies
we'd hold parties cucumber sandwiches
exactly some old money
thank you very much uh it's been a
neighborhood treasure for years our
house Jesus
people look at our house and they cry
emotions and joy yeah can you bring your
trash cans in trash day was yesterday
it's an eyesore non-sequitur but my
husband is also the mayor like get the
[ __ ] out of here dude um until
developers snatched up the lot next door
or bulldozing a wreck an enormous house
that blocked out the light to most of
the garden many of us tried to fight it
with the city but everything was denied
it was heartbreaking our neighborhood
has been changed forever this was a link
to my family and I almost have to go
through a grieving process for Jesus
Christ lady please do and then kill
yourself I'm sorry I hope your husband
cheats on you he probably is and that's
why she's so focused yeah this is
[ __ ] oh my God oh my God he's been
cheating on her since 92. let's be right
since he got to know her he's been
cheating on us
um the new owners moved in and were not
welcomed warmly in the neighborhood oh
geez I avoided them for as long as I
could other than politely waving or
nodding it was a couple it was a young
couple in their early 20s okay they're
mad that they have the money to the
record Brandon and youth yeah that's
what it really is we finally came face
to face with the woman and asked if we
could chat she said that they felt like
maybe they've done something wrong when
they moved in or if they aren't pulling
in their trash bins or something being
too loud Etc because people haven't been
very friendly the guy says that he's
surprise considering it felt like a nice
and somewhat affluent neighborhood and
given the price he was expecting
friendly neighbors I asked if they have
done any research about the area they
said they moved from California so no
no
she just stealed her face
from Oklahoma
and that's where she knew yeah yeah oh
my god
um they said they moved from California
so no they didn't do research and I said
well maybe that was their mistake
they said they didn't know what I meant
so I asked if they'd ever looked into
our backyard they said yes and said they
think the garden is cute I said
they use the wrong word there with her I
think yeah I mean it's cute I said quote
yes the garden that now has about a half
less sunlight than before that house was
built was a neighborhood treasure the
guy said she said it again yeah guys
neighborhood the guy's a blue ribbon
over it yeah yeah oh my god the guy says
there's the Council of the judges too
King of the city the guys are the
treasure the guy says well or quote well
it's not our fault you built the garden
there is it I said well you guys got
what you paid for for two million
dollars for our house that everyone in
the neighborhood hates I said that I
hoped it was worth it and wished them a
nice day when I told another name you're
a [ __ ] sorry I was gonna say yeah
she's a [ __ ] yeah I wish them a nice day
did you were like have a nice day yeah
yeah
oh God uh when I told another neighbor
about the exchange she told me that she
does feel better for the moving without
having any idea what they were getting
them so I don't know Peggy Sue I kind of
feel bad for them yeah this is a
conversation you shut your mouth yeah
yeah am I the [ __ ] for telling them
that they got what they paid for yes
you're an [ __ ] for way more than that
oh my God okay let's start with that
[ __ ] that was the last [ __ ] reason of
why you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] lady okay
she finally had a glimmer of like am I
mean
your ability to be an [ __ ] is a
national [ __ ] treasure okay
oh [ __ ] dude you are the [ __ ] of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] like what
she thinks she's singing for the whole
neighborhood and she's like I'm gonna be
the representative of this atrocity yeah
and I'll put them in their place yeah
did she expect them to be like you know
what me like when they looked it up on
Zillow or whatever like maybe we
shouldn't have we shouldn't move in here
because look at that Garden I was just
there's a treasure it looks like it
might be near our neighborhood treasure
I feel like we should look at a
different address how would any anyone
know exactly they're the plans that
their architect created yeah but somehow
ruin this neighborhood like you don't
[ __ ] think about it does she think
like they went oh a garden let's cover
an exchange yeah over like how do we
destroy this Garden yeah like it's so
personal exactly I don't think these
people even had any say on this how this
was built they just found the house and
wanted to move it I mean a lot where
this neighborhood's getting gentrified
we're gonna start it yeah I mean I would
have told her like you know ma'am you
should be happy that we were willing to
spend this kind of money yeah such a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know we're just trying to support
our small business of making avocado
toast that's on the corner and we do
yoga on Sundays you're invited
yeah
oh my God the driveway is just lined
with them yeah
um
Jesus
I want to know how old this person is so
bad she's a thousand percent she's over
50. yeah I would I would bet mine you're
like not quite old enough to not give a
[ __ ] anymore like if you're like 70s 80s
you're like ah [ __ ] I don't care yeah
but like she's between like 50 and 63.
yeah I would say yeah you're like you
got time she has she has too much time
she probably hasn't ever had to work
because the house has been in her family
for years yeah she doesn't even know
what it means like I'm princess of the
neighborhood so we're talking about how
much a house is is totally irrelevant
because that house is probably twenty
thousand dollars in 19 [ __ ] 20. when
her family bought him I wouldn't bet
she's the only person that thinks that
her garden is so incredible in this
neighborhood I want to bet that the
entire neighborhood [ __ ] hates yeah
yeah and they just to appease her and
not deal with her [ __ ] hey Karen
how's it going yeah Garden looks
beautiful today yeah they're like get
the [ __ ] away from me I don't want to
start [ __ ] with this leg no she said she
said that the other day the whole
neighborhood though has been cold to her
so maybe they're all like that or maybe
they're just I think they're just going
they're just nowhere to not deal with
her [ __ ] yeah maybe but also like if
I could be old money and living there
forever who knows but I wouldn't if I
was like just dealing with Karen's
[ __ ] like when I did see the new
neighbor I would still be like hey yeah
you know like I wouldn't be like
yeah or that's also what she's telling
us yeah the neighbors could be being
lovely to them yeah you know what I mean
like maybe she added that part because
yeah this lady is the one telling the
stories she was like yeah and she
noticed that the other neighbor is like
we're in yeah yeah being nice to her
either it's like well maybe we should
just added as much as they suck up to
her ass to get her shut up for this lady
story have drained my [ __ ] life
Source like I cannot with her what the
[ __ ]
um top comment says deal with that [ __ ]
right top comment says so you unloaded
your pen up anger at the developers on
the couple who un unwittingly bought the
house you're the [ __ ] that couple did
nothing wrong they bought a house that
was on the market now if they had been
the ones to buy the house uh from the
previous owner bulldoze it down then
built their multi-million dollar mansion
he might have a leg to stand on but from
what you say in the post the
neighborhood is taking out their
frustration anger on an innocent couple
yeah The Flipper like yeah honestly the
person who sold the house sold your
neighborhood out yeah it's not the new
person's fault like when the
neighborhood starts turning or whatever
it's all everyone else [ __ ] sold out
yeah not the new people's fault yeah
that's true and are they supposed to
[ __ ] like sit there in the house and
just watch the sunset whatever to see if
it is there's enough sun in your garden
responsibility for your property what
the [ __ ] is this no one thinks of that
oh my gosh I will say though
if my neighbors built a like five-story
house that covered my house in shade
I would be mad but it wouldn't be it's
like if the new neighbors moved in it's
not their fault it's not old neighbors
but also she did say it used to get more
sun so it's not like it's covering the
whole you know what I mean like I feel
like it's probably maybe a quarter and a
half now is in the shade yeah like the
squash is gonna die now this woman seems
like she's exaggerated some of the time
I'm gonna go you know I was trying to
think of the only way that I would ever
like yeah that's a good point but again
it's not the new person's fault like you
said like yeah yeah the people who moved
out and did that dicks yeah also that's
the one case for HOAs is that with with
HOAs the neighbors have to sign off on
anything you're doing to your house
that's gonna affect their house right so
yeah this was already approved yeah yeah
yeah uh second comment says you're the
[ __ ] they just bought a house that's
all they did can you imagine a poor
young couple yeah that could get it
together and have to buy a house at 24
bucks not a lot of people which is
awesome that they did that yeah
there's kind of like a war like that in
my neighborhood where right now because
when when I bought our house in Montana
where you live
Iowa
[Music]
there's a when I first bought it we
bought it because like it's well in the
desert there's like Lakes like in this
neighborhood only and there's like
man-made beaches and it looks like a
freaking Oasis and so I'm like oh I'd be
fell in love with the neighborhood but
our Realtors were like it's kind of a
retirement community you know just you
know like it's like more quiet like
mellow blah blah I'm like that's fine
you know like we work at home we're not
a lot of people we don't have like dogs
parties yeah we're not Partiers or
anything but I was kind of like oh I
kind of wish that there was like like I
hope that there's like one couple that's
already just like hang out and like have
game nights with or whatever and it
ended up that on our street in
particular like it's a little gated
community so it's like little like not
straight it's like a little side streets
yeah yeah on our street is like all the
people our age like 30s and they all
moved in within the past like five years
and like half of us are from California
and like the older neighbors hate us
like they think that we're just like
taking the neighborhood even though we
don't do anything different like we're
not still alive it's still quiet and all
and for like for old uh like young
adults yeah like we're older 30s or
early 40s and like we're just like
having wine nights or whatever not loud
or anything Millennial Boulevard
we leave our trash cans out like like
two minutes after you're supposed to
take them in we're a citation
one of our neighbors got a citation
because she had dust on her walls no
dust because there was wind and then she
got too much dust on her walls this is
because people are because they're old
and they're bored yeah this is why you
gotta think about when you're gonna
retire you gotta have something else
you're gonna do because our fascia
boards which I didn't I had to [ __ ]
Google with a fashion I'm sorry it's the
thing that you rub on your legs
yeah the fashion yeah she doesn't know
his first song
and that shows like the stuff that keeps
the fat in I'm sorry guys I don't know
what that is yeah
it's just the it's the little like piece
of wood over your uh garage door
you had a little [ __ ] thing like I
guess a piece of it the paint kind of
chipped off a little bit and so they're
like we're gonna find you 100
degenerates if you don't fix this 100 a
week yeah so I got a painter to paint it
and they're like you didn't get the
Painter approved
holy [ __ ] dude you can't [ __ ] win
nope yeah
they're like if you don't fix this in
two weeks you're gonna get charged 100 a
week and then I sent the approval to get
my [ __ ] painter approved and they
never respond three months went by they
never responded and then they sent me
another citation
to [ __ ] fix this and you didn't but
where's the approval exactly but did
they give you a bill for 100 a week
insane I was like thank God I put
everything in writing too in the email
it was smart yeah I was like I need
yeah they told me I couldn't have my
painter come in until I got approved I
sent him my approval form and then they
never responded unbelievable on you bro
but yeah they like go around like just
waiting for a lot of us to [ __ ] up
there's someone with a [ __ ] checklist
yes walking the streets so if you don't
abide by these things and and just rack
up a [ __ ] can they kick you out yeah
they can take a lean on your house yeah
are you joking yeah
too much power we're just renting for
Life yeah that's what you're they're
like you should get on the board of an
HOA if you can yeah but I don't want to
[ __ ] waste I used to do bookkeeping
for an HOA when I was in college and I
was like yeah I will always 100 be on
the board because they are a bunch of
[ __ ] dumb asses and it's all like the
seniority [ __ ] so they was like
original owners so the neighborhood was
built in the 90s and there's like they
take pride in the fact that they were
like the original owners like one of the
few original owners left yeah
it's not 19 [ __ ] seconds
okay cool you retired here thought you
were just gonna be around about the
retirees and then like turns out people
like the neighborhood so they moved in
and they're younger than you like that's
all that happened your property values
are solid and that's okay do you care
about this neighborhood you're
eventually all going to die off then
what no one can live here because it's
just a ghost town yeah exactly crazy but
yeah there's a definitely a war that's
all my youngers are trying to modernize
this neighborhood oh my god
um so she never responded to any account
or to any of the comments uh but this
one says uh too busy uh quote did you
research the neighborhood like is your
garden a big thing so well known that
it's in the papers that people should
know about it without having to talk to
the neighbors for moving into specific
talks and even then they did not design
the house just bought it it is not their
fault you're being angry at them as it
is yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] man yeah [ __ ]
I'm like I want to buy a plot of land
right outside the limits in This Woman's
neighborhood and just start burning
trash in the backyard I just want to set
our foot in the garden
yeah
something that'll kill all the
vegetables yeah she's one of those that
if you park outside of her house she
like leaves a note on your car yeah can
you not Park your vehicle yeah
like this exists oh crazy
one is am I the [ __ ] for refusing to
give this woman her Grandma's wedding
dress and jewelry back probably I'm
gonna go with a hard yes on this I am
willing to change my mind but I'm pretty
decided because we've been bamboozled by
these times yeah I know yeah the titles
are a little bit they do like to cook
betas yeah it's so good we're suckers
i 26 year old female bought a hoarder
house back in May 2018. it was a big six
bedroom and four and a half bathroom
house when I bought it the contract
stated that I take ownership of the
house and everything in it the lady who
owned it died and her heirs could not
deal with the stench and literal
mountain of junk and wasting it you
clean it you keep it that's the that's
the deal with that it's like you're
buying it as is this house could have
the foundation rotted you don't know
what you're buying and that's like part
of the deal is like okay but if there's
a family fortune in there you get to
have it I see yeah oh it's the risk you
take wow and you think the risk you
could only open the door not even eight
inches and some room had the junk
filling them wall to wall floor to
ceiling well it took me these pet last
four years to finish cleaning fixing and
updating it while doing the cleaning I
made sure to check everything before
throwing it out uh ended with more than
twenty thousand dollars worth of money
some nice jewelries and antique
furniture those hoarders always got
[ __ ] Treasures in there that's where
the Storage Wars show exists holy [ __ ]
yeah and finally a stunning 40 style
lace covered wedding dress this woman
took care that took care of that dress
until she couldn't anymore and it took
just some minor work to restore it I
currently don't have a partner but I
decided that it would be the dress I'll
be wearing if I ever get married wow
while doing the cleaning I wish The
Heirs to pass on some pictures and
mementos uh Christmas a person she
didn't have to do that yeah
she's already doing too much yeah yeah
um like some Christmas personalized
ornaments some kids artwork yada yada
and because of that I had one of them
30s female in my Facebook friends list
because I reached out after repairing
the dress I put it on with the jewelry
and posted a pic on Facebook well this
woman saw it and as for the dress and
heirlooms back I refuse to give them
back and legally they can't do anything
yeah also if they meant that much of
them they should have cleaned the house
exactly not sell it to me yep now she
and all her family are calling me out on
social media am I the [ __ ] no not at
all she's not the [ __ ] at all but
um I think she probably made a little
bit of a mistake if I'm looking at it
from like okay could she have avoided
this yeah she shouldn't have reached out
to get anything don't realize that's not
part of the deal right you got it so
pictures of stuff yeah
lot of times with like kids that get
adopted like they're biological parents
if you like [ __ ] 12 years later
they'll try to like yeah yeah you're
playing with fire there like I feel like
she should have just gone fully like how
she could have just avoided that
happening to her yeah would have been
just been like whatever she didn't want
she tossed and there was no connection
with these people yeah because then that
would have never happened that person
would have never seen it so I think she
could have done something better to
avoid it but I don't think she's the
[ __ ] yeah it's hard now though
knowing that you have someone's
Grandma's stuff and you're like but it's
mine legally you know so it's still kind
now it's like do you really want it yeah
like it's a little weird it's like I get
that you don't have to give it back
clearly she has no family because she's
thinking about wearing someone else's
Grandmother's Restaurant yeah so it's a
little weird now I want to be like no
I'm keeping it but it's like I would be
like begrudgingly like [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
yeah because I'm just gonna give it the
part I don't like is like here's this
worthless like pictures that I found
that were Drew but I'm keeping the air
alone but because yeah it's like then
don't do that at all no just [ __ ]
throw it away and now you've befriended
this person on Facebook yeah I couldn't
do it to my friend no and you're posting
a picture she didn't think about it she
didn't think about how I'm posting this
picture [ __ ] that person saw it you know
on the other hand I feel like that would
have been something like I would do like
oh these are really sweet family like
maybe somebody really misses this and
watched yeah so I would reach out to
them befriending them on Facebook that's
a little bit yeah
keeping contacts a little weird yeah
um so that but yeah there was no
responsibility to clean the [ __ ]
house out yeah yeah they wanted all of
them [ __ ] to be gone they wanted to [ __ ]
it give us some money you don't get the
reward if you didn't do the work yeah
and she restored it she said she
probably paid money to have that extra
storage spend money on yeah and four
years yeah that place must have been
like this is so intense yeah it's so
much money to spend on cleaning yeah
yeah I feel like uh if she had reached
out and was like here are the ornaments
and like they told me like oh my God
thank you so much like
um we loved our grandmother but we lost
contact we didn't know where she was
blah blah okay I think kind of yeah you
know what here take more stuff because
you guys obviously are heartbroken about
this did you find her wedding dress or
something yeah they said I don't know
you know yeah it didn't give a [ __ ] at
all until the picture exactly yeah yeah
like use it all the work can I have that
yeah yeah I wonder though if they knew
how much worth like the jewelry and
everything
or they just saw the dress like if they
saw the Facebook post and said holy [ __ ]
look at this dress I found in 20 000
with whatever and then all of a sudden
the family's like hey I really want that
I'm gonna need that dress back yeah or
was it just like hey I found this
beautiful dress and they're like oh my
God that's Grandma's dress we have
pictures of hers
that context matters yeah I think so
yeah for sure yeah so the comments are
um top comment and consensus says not
the [ __ ] uh recovering hoarder here
legally you are in the right morally you
are also in the right and though I
cannot speak for the woman whose things
you now own I can give you insight into
how I would feel if I died before I
could find homes for my treasures I
would want someone who cared enough to
restore and respect items to have them
you saw the beauty in them as did she
you didn't just Chuck it all in the
dumpster yeah wear them and be or be
happy to honor the original owner her
family did not view those things as
anything but a hassle yep that's a nice
comment I like that I like that too uh
the next comment says not the [ __ ]
you bought it and then more importantly
you did a [ __ ] ton of work to save and
restore these things honestly if I were
the grandmother I'd rather have my stuff
go to a random stranger who gave a damn
than anyone else also on that note I'm
gonna call out everyone in the comments
fortunately not that many who say that
this dress is more important to the
family member um no it's not that
important to the family their
convenience was more important yeah now
that all the hard work is done son
my grandmother was a hoarder and my
family spent months cleaning out her
house after she died we did that because
our family heirlooms in history meant
something to us it wasn't easy it was
costly and time consuming and miserable
and really important you don't get to
come back later after all the work is
done and decide you're suddenly entitled
to the fruit of someone else's work yeah
yeah I see all these people that
understand they lived with hoarders or
they were Horrors or whatever yeah yeah
it's so different it's not just like
well there's a little bit of a mess yeah
you found that can I have it back yeah
no that's like a [ __ ] ton of mess and
like it could have rotted the house like
she has to invest in that yeah four
years yeah that is a lot of [ __ ] to go
through I want I know and now I'm
curious I want to see what the dress
looks like I know me too does it show
you I imagine it being like a long time
like so it's probably so beautiful yeah
probably yeah like you can't find
anything like that now yeah like that
well made yeah yeah all right well
that's our episode for am I the [ __ ]
which like see it was fun right I Had
the Time of My Life is
[Laughter]
and if you're that crazy roommate lady
don't we you don't know us we don't know
you we never read your story yeah but
you're an [ __ ]
um but I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode with our great friend Jay here
Jay tell them where they can find you
what's your link
um jokes by Jay Jay both on Instagram
and Tick Tock and that's kind of where I
live I don't really live anywhere else
and uh that's all I need yeah so thanks
so thank you to our special guest thank
you for sitting here and helping us
judge people the neighborhood treasure
treasure
make sure you guys check out our socials
and our sponsors down below like And
subscribe and we love you we'll see you
guys next week bye
[Music]